Dude. I think when people are
immune to have dicks in the future,
it just seems like everything's
going away so fast, man.
They're trying to do that with this new,
a Gillette commercial.
I've seen that Gillette commercial
[inaudible] I heard about it that you can
shave your buddy or something.
That's really mad because it's like an
anti masculine Gillette commercial and
makes like every man look like
a massage and his piece of shit.
It's such a disturbing commercial.
It's like over and over again.
Men doing douchey shit like, hey
bro, aren't you selling razors?
Do and you changing the world with
your shitty fucking advertiser based
philosophy. What are you
doing? Like what are you doing?
Who fucking green lit this? How's
Atlanta? But like, Yo Yo yo guys,
people get hair.
They want to fucking shave it.
You're not getting it fixed.
Imagine if you are of sexist rapist
piece of shit and you see that Gillette
commercial like, damn, I got to switch my
game. I've been too much of a dick. Like,
does anybody think that
Gillette commercials or
somehow or another in any way,
shape or form going to affect
culture is bad. You're selling.
Razors is bad.
It's just a razor.
I'd rather break my fucking face
here than by Gillette. Again,
he wants to be lectured to
wear a tie or heard of that.
So sick of that.
You don't have your shit together.
Nobody has their shit together.
And you telling people how to get their
shit together in a fucking razor blade
at yeah. Yeah. Don't be racist. We know.
Yeah. Don't be a sexist. Yeah, we know.
We know. Most people aren't.
Yeah. This is like, you got it.
Like most people are the videos, like
most people. All right. It's not,
most people are crazy.
That's a disproportionate
amount of people that are,
that's what I hate about it. A lot
of the, this, a lot of these ideas,
the ideology today, it's
like, like they say,
everybody where I'm from is racist or
everybody's like, uh, you know, um,
some Christian Bible thumping.
And that's true.
So many of the people I know are not
that at all that it's unbelievable.
But so many of the people in
some and these other places,
they don't even know anybody from there.
So it's like they have no idea,
but they immediately stereotyped
because of your accent too.
You have a southern accent. People assume
you're not bright. Yeah, it's so stupid.
But it's also, it's indicative of
what the place used to be like.
Like what the world used to be like was
like a lot of the rural edge areas were
less educated. Now that
there's the internet, the world
is a different place, man.
You can meet cool people in Wichita,
Kansas. You meet cool people everywhere.
Everywhere you go, you're going to
run into pockets of cool people. Cool.
People are everywhere, man.
So good people. Good people
are everywhere and they're,
they have different values and a lot
of them are more community oriented,
more friendly.